now and then many of us think about
making big changes in our lives well for
yuko shimizu there were two daunting
ones all at once she left japan for the
u.s and she left a stable career to try
her hand as an artist well those bold
moves have paid off her award-winning
creations are seen in some of the
nation's top newspapers and magazines
and in ads for some of the world's
biggest companies and that's just part
of her impressive portfolio christina
rouffini has her story
in worlds imagined by artist yuko
shimizu
realism tumbles into fantasy
of color barely contained by strong
deliberate lines
[Music]
what is your art like
it's a funny question i mean i get asked
that all the time each intricate
illustration begins in black and white
the inky backbones of bold exacting
brush strokes
when
non-japanese person sees my work they
always say my work looks very japanese
and when japanese person sees it they
say it's very americanized
japanese art
that's because the art like the artist
is an energetic blend of traditional
japanese influences and the vibrant
creativity of her adopted city new york
and what is it about new york that you
find inspiring
because it's very diverse and then
coming from japan and living here for a
long time i don't consider myself either
japanese or american so what are you
i'm neither and i'm fine with that okay
and
new york seems like the only place that
like you can be anything and anyone and
it's okay and accepted
growing up in japan in the 1970s yuko's
artistic aspirations weren't exactly
encouraged you know kindergarten teacher
asked us
what do you want to be when you grow up
most of the little girl said they want
to be a pretty bride
and i say i want to be a painter and
painter artist was just not on the
pre-approved list no her family moved
briefly to the u.s when she was in
middle school where she says she didn't
fit in then back to japan where she
suddenly felt too american
eventually she stopped drawing to pursue
a career in pr but at age 34 she quit
enrolled in art school and moved back to
new york how did you end up deciding
that you wanted to go back to art school
so
a lot of reasons
at the end
what was there was i
said i wanted to be a painter at age
five or six
but i never pursued it why didn't i
pursue it
because people said it's a phase there
are people who are more talented than
you
um you were not gonna make a living
being an artist
and then at that time i realized you
know like as cheesy as it is you only
live once
shimizu slowly grew her portfolio from
newspapers and magazines then to more
than 70 comic book covers and an
award-winning children's book
eventually came big name clients like
target mtv
and an asian-american comedian
so this is a sketch you did
for ali wong yes
she had a new show and it was her merch
first she sketches rough thumbnails to
play with composition
then starts in on the larger ink drawing
finally she scans the image and
manipulates the color digitally in this
case adding fireballs and superhero
sparkles i love women
who
just like stand tall and work in the
male dominant
world for women no matter how much money
power or respect you earn
you are never allowed to behave badly
and get away with it
but that's all i wanna do
what is it about her that's that you
identify with she
is asian in a way she talks about
how asian asian-americans are and the
way we relate to and being asian in
america lately has been hard anti-asian
violence has spiked during the pandemic
especially in new york
she now works from home because she
doesn't feel safe staying late at her
midtown studio
i hope things get resolved but like
it's terrible but if anything good came
out of it people know
shimizu doesn't shy away from social
justice issues
she created this piece at the height of
me too i wanted to come out with an
image that every woman can relate to
and everybody can relate to having that
feeling of people's eyes
but not every work needs to have a
message some are just plain fun
so what are we gonna go see uh we're
gonna go see my new mural in the hue
it's called waterloo water lilies yeah
all right at this revamped food hall
shimizu wanted customers to feel happy
and calm so what inspired this
installation
so you know this is a communal space so
i thought about what is a pleasant thing
to put in a communal space and i thought
about moma
you know there's a big water release
painting by monet so i wanted you know
like to see if i can modernize it and
make it into a mural but despite her
quite literally large success
shimizu says art can be a fickle field
if i start to feel everything is okay
i'm set then i think your life is over
so
you have that little bit of fear to keep
yourself going always always leaving her
lines like her life
space to blossom grow and flow creating
our work is hard right like it is our
passion but it's so hard
so at least the process has to be
something rewarding and for me to be
rewarding i have to figure stuff out as
i go
for cbs saturday morning christina
rafini new york
her pieces are simply irresistible and
the art look at this look around
surrounding us right now was created by
yuko and
she collaborated with art tech house for
an interactive and immersive art exhibit
back in 2020 but would you look it's
stunning it's stunning it's stunning
it's unbelievable it's interesting how
she says americans think her work looks
japanese yeah japanese think her work
looks american
it's just beautiful somewhere in exactly
right it is beautiful